angefahren vergewaltigt und dann einfach
weggeschmissen
der brutale mord an einer
wissenschaftlerin aus deutschland
vergangenes jahr auf der sonneninsel
kreta erschütterte ganz europa es ist
der zweite juli 2009 10 zu sein eaton
ist für eine konferenz auf kreta sp
kommt mit dem auto vom holz sammeln also
die 59 jährige beim joggen beobachtet
nach eigenen aussagen spürte er eine
übermächtige macht der frau zufolge
näher wollte sex mit einer fremden haben
wenn es sein muss mit gewalt
jan s p überfährt gegen mit seinem auto
zweimal erlebt die schwer verletzte
frauen seinen kofferraum für 12 km zu
einer höhle und vergewaltigt sein opfer
dort dreimal zu diesem zeitpunkt sollten
bewusstlos oder sogar bereits tot
gewesen sein
anschließend wirft jan s p die
forscherin in einen sieben meter tiefen
höhlen schacht wo sie später von hobby
munition zur an gefunden wird es war
offenbar nicht das erste mal dass jan sp
versuchte eine frau in seine gewalt zu
bringen
die tarife war an himmelfahrt 2009 10
mit dem fahrrad auf kreta unterwegs als
sie mit einem auto angefahren wurde bin
ich langsam weiter gefahren in dem
offenen der see vorbeizieht und der
weiße wagen also das habe ich noch nicht
gesehen erst als der vorzug und nun
meine armbeuge sah ich dann noch einmal
einen weißen kotflügel dachte der über
überholt und im nächsten augenblick
zieht der links river und ich verliere
das bewusstsein und sie bin dann war
wieder wach geworden paar sekunden
später so wenn es das können nur 23
sekunden ist gewesen sein
und dann ging das fahrrad eben da drin
und ich mit der hand im zaun und ganz an
die seite gepresst und tage später durch
auch hier wieder zur seite voller
prellungen
doch terry war hatte glück im unglück
sie bricht sich bei dem zwischenfall nur
die hand ja so wie es aussieht denn wenn
es das gleiche war wie die von wie das
von der susanne eben dann hatte ich eben
das glück dass der wagen sich an der
t-kreuzung sei dass er links abfuhr von
der gleichen richtungen
ein ehepaar kam mit einem traktor und
anhänger und im nachhinein konnte mir
nicht ein zweites mal was antun also das
wäre natürlich ein leichtes gewesen so
angeschlagen wie ich war nur das
auftauchen weiterer passanten rettete
kette rewe wahrscheinlich das leben zu
sein ihnen hatte dieses glück nicht
13 tage nach dem mord fasste die polizei
jan s p er hat die tat gestanden und auf
kreta für uns meine kollegin claudia
lord du hast den prozess gestern für uns
beobachtet wie lief das ganze ab
guten morgen aus kreta ja das ist
richtig in dem gerichtsgebäude hinter
mir gab es gestern zum späten abend das
urteil überraschend für alle da
innerhalb eines tages der täter zu
lebenslang verurteilt wurde er bekam
außerdem 13 jahre strafe für die
vergewaltigungen die er selbst im
gericht noch bestritt jedoch war sich
das gericht dass aus einer richterin und
sechs beisitzern aus der bevölkerung
bestand einig dass die platte gibt die
tat geplant war und der täter so lange
wie möglich in haft kommen sollte und
des opfers auf dieses urteil reagiert
wir wissen vom anwalt der familie dass
die schwester die ja als einzige
angehörige der familie im gerichtssaal
saß und ganz zu beginn ausgesagt hatte
das urteil positiv aufgenommen hat sie
zeigen sich damit zufrieden weil sie
wissen dass es die höchststrafe ist die
im krieg im griechischen gesetz möglich
ist wobei die familie nach wie vor sehr
traumatisiert ist von dem ganzen fall
die schwester hat beispiel darum gebeten
dass sie dem killer nicht ins gesicht
blicken muss deswegen wurde die
sitzordnung im gerichtssaal extra
geändert
der angeklagte sei es die ganzen zehn
stunden verhandelt worden
direkt vor der richterin mit dem rücken
zum saal und auch mit dem rücken zum
zeugenstand in denen die schwester trat
und sie hat einfach ihren auftritt oder
ihrer zeugenaussage auch noch mal dazu
benützt zu sagen was für eine tolle
kluge frau ihre schwester war wie sehr
sie der familie fehlt
und dass alle im grunde genommen noch
sehr damit beschäftigt sind diese tat zu
verarbeiten konnte man trotzdem
irgendwelche regungen beim angeklagten
sehen ihnen irgendwie erkennen
einschätzen wie er das ganze jetzt
aufgenommen hat eigentlich nicht also
das war für mich wirklich das
schockierende dass er die ganzen zehn
stunden ruhig emotionslos im
gerichtssaal saß es wurden aus dem
polizeiprotokoll die einzelheiten dieser
gräulichen tat vorgelesen wo man als
frau wirklich nur friert selbst die
bewaffneten polizisten die im saal waren
haben nach unten geblickt wussten nicht
wie sie darauf reagieren sollen und er
saß da bewegte sich nicht ich habe auch
den anwalt der familie ihnen nochmal
gefragt der seitlich auf sein gesicht
blicken konnte er hat mir bestätigt da
war gar nicht das einzige die einzige
reaktion war er hätte kurz geschluckt
als er von seiner lebenslangen
haftstrafe wird mehr nachrichten und
break linie es nur bei bild schau dir
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren